and we'll see his Vibes I think
sometimes because women don't see looks
first if he's feminine he starts talking
like a girl and he don't like women
you don't like women if he's talking to
me
if you ever had a guy that was very
attractive then he opened his mouth and
he like sounds like a girl and his voice
is so high pitched and you're like oh
God
I'll assume he said
I can't say it coming
um okay so if so going back to the prize
analogy if women date up and they claim
they're the prize
and she is the prize in a relationship
then isn't that relationship destined to
fail
if I can say that again sorry so if
women if women claims that she's the
prize isn't that relationship destined
to fail because women date up
I don't want to speak for us okay you're
quiet I feel like you got it yeah
King I'm not sure
I just think the man is the head I feel
like the man is the head the woman is
the neck we all work as one so women
don't actually know how much power they
have in regards to like you could get a
man to do something just by maybe
advising or changing the way you speak
and it can be done so if we're going
technically I would say yeah because for
her to be what was the context of of the
question so if she thinks she's the
prize already
I already think that we need to
understand that the man
you see the word prize is a bit have you
okay have you ever seen a girl that like
genuinely feels like she married down oh
and like like that she she runs the show
she is her husband by that it's like she
she walks all over here does that does
that like that's horrible to see I don't
like that because I feel like the man
like he's just disrespectful when he
when he puts her on a pedestal yeah like
Will Smith remember a couple I called I
called Will Smith before any when he was
remember at all the awards shows girls
don't like that they don't respect that
but in that relationship she she he felt
like she was the prize and now and now
you have one of the a guy in the top one
percent of looks money
I think it used to be muscles sorry but
like looking stupid he looks like a fool
because of his woman the whole that
relationship has failed then
partially yeah because she like Jada
Jada wanted to be with a Tupac and so
and that's what that's what that's when
we go back to the bad boys and the nice
guys well because he picked a girl he
picked a girl that had been ran through
by by Tupac yeah
he got two pucks leftovers
so I think you mentioned something where
you said um
it was along the lines of you guys have
basically gassed up the girl
to make like you said she thinks people
like her but they don't it's just her
looks so therefore you guys have played
that role but I was also going to say
you know how the women the term women
are mad I think we are visibly more mad
because we act out I also think there
are some guys whether it's narcissistic
Tendencies or psychologically they may
and it's not seen on social media or
it's not seen out there all we see is
the woman going mad the woman burning
shoes the woman doing this but I feel
like sometimes you get a lot of Mad Men
who's true I don't know what they
studied but they get into a woman's head
and it may not be like he's actively
doing something but those men were
raised by women
I'll tell you that now those men were
raised by men what those Tendencies
you're talking about the acts of
manipulation get into your head and
that's what women do that's what women
do to their husbands that's what women
do when they have kids
that's women so the men you're talking
about goes back to women angry woman
and at the end of the day women are in
control of relationships I know men get
to pick who they're in a relationship
with but you could argue that women are
in control because we're in control sex
and these days that seems to come first
so we're picking so if we we hate the
toxic and we hate the manipulative guys
why are we sleeping with them
I think can I just add to this
conversation so for me I don't we use
this term toxic masculinity I don't
believe that you can be masculine and be
toxic you're either toxic and you're not
serving your purpose so you're not a man
um I don't I don't know if you would
agree I don't think toxic masculinity is
a real thing I think that's what I'm
saying yeah I don't think that's a real
thing it's not you can't be masculine
and be toxic you're just not masculine
so if you have toxic traits when you
look back at people these men who are on
social media shouting carrying on a
certain way feeding into a certain type
of dynamic these are the same women that
flock to those same men and we have to
ask ourselves why are we why are we
flocking to them is it because we see a
similarity but sorry
um because women love drama no no but
that's what I was about to say do we see
the similarity between ourselves and
that man if it is a feminine trait it is
a feminine trait so women love drama no
no that's why yeah women love drama a
lot of women love drama because it feeds
into their emotional need I feel why
don't women watch the NBA why don't
women watch the NBA where a team is
coming together and they but they watch
the Kardashians
they're The Bachelor but that's what I'm
saying wait it's not all but but I'm
saying generally speaking women women
yeah women like drama generally speaking
when if we first of all I can say they
wouldn't watch the NBA because it
doesn't feed into their validation
circuit certain avoid doesn't feed into
their emotional circuits it doesn't have
drama so no important so with the
Kardashians I've never watched them so I
don't really know but I will say it is
tailored to appeal to women to validate
their need to have superficial am I
talking so much about superficial gains
and having the higher value man that
they deserve you you know look at the
Social Circles that we're in it's very
messy because of where we are in the
social classes if you look at people
with more body they don't have to cover
their stuff up they know how to okay I'm
gonna mess around over here but when I
turn 30 or 35 I'm gonna marry a woman
who's in my social class we're going to
have our stuff together and we're going
to have kids that we're going to have a
family I might take Coke in the back or
I might do my food no no rule this is
real life when you're in a class a lower
class like myself everyone here working
class we're messy we don't we jump from
this to that to that and whatever we can
get it's a free-for-all
I was gonna say
I possibly what she's saying because
let's say I've had friends maybe in a
higher social class you realize that
they really cover each other yeah and
I've realized whether it's illegal
whether it's not legal whether it's
drugs whether it's sex even with like
the whole what do you mean cover each
other so as in let's say there's a
scandal okay there's we're gonna sign an
NBA and we're gonna keep this between us
it's not going to go anywhere it's
covered whereas I get what she's saying
why is Hollywood so messy
Hollywood is not a real place I feel
like it's just it's it's drama literally
it's make believe and it's drama I feel
like when you go into the real world and
you start meeting real people those
classes someone's son has knocked over
someone attempted no this is
and it's so crazy because I feel like as
people you need to understand and try
and delve into different social classes
to understand that stop staying where
you are that's how you're doing it but
the point is that women in general like
drama yeah yeah I agree with that yeah
but if it feeds into emotional news
but it doesn't matter like like where
who cares why we just do one one it's
attention women love attention right
attention we love it
um different varies from Woman to Woman
me personally I can do about it you're
probably the ladies who could agree
limited attention we don't need that
whole Spotlight
um and then the validation that is
that's what carries it if you're getting
validated by 300 girls on social media
talk about I I love you you're right you
should do this you should it doesn't
happen for men though I'm saying like
average no average look they've done
studies average looking girls get more
messages than top 10 guys yeah the
question for the girls yeah so I think
you agreed that um less attention would
be good right
the age I might yeah yeah I know so
would you stop wearing makeup and doing
that yourself okay so I've I'm gonna so
just about backstory I was a tomboy up
until very recently I just about learned
how to do makeup the other day I think
it's just about I'm I'm I can go out
confidently that way I make up I prefer
not to it it's very annoying unless
there's a special occasion I might wear
it but that's what I'm saying there's a
minority then there's generalism I
personally I don't like it I just feel
like do you guys have Instagram yeah so
how can you say you hate attention if
you're interested so all of my socials
on private and and and I would I tell
people this I know everybody on my
social media as in whether it's
secondary school I'm not posting for
clarification if my thing will be open
if I wanted I'm posting for maybe family
updates or because I like traveling I'm
showing what I'm doing so that's what
I'm saying I might be the minority but I
get it even on a small scale though
you're still looking for attention in
some level yeah like I mean I'm not
saying I'm saying you're not I'm not
saying you're not you're not to the
level of like the girls posting their
ass on ideas